let's talk about Anthony Weiner it seems
that the Anthony Weiner scandal is sort
of wrapping up with prison time that
Anthony Weiner has been sentenced for
Anthony Weiner is the former Democratic
New York congressman former New York
City mayoral candidate sentenced to 21
months in prison he faced up to 27 he
ultimately got 21 he pleaded guilty to a
charge of transferring obscene material
to a minor in sort of layman's terms
that means sexting with a teenage girl
that's that's what the guy actually did
he has until November 6 to report to
prison to start his sentence he has
since said that he is quote a very sick
man for a very long time and that he is
quote profoundly sorry he read from a
page in front of him at the sentencing
adding that quote the crime I committed
was my rock bottom I live a different
and better life today does anyone really
believe he's leading a different and
better life today I mean every time he
had three four five of these scandals
that we know about publicly and every
single time he was turning over and you
leave I don't remember if he was one of
the people that did the sex addict
therapy which is always a popular move
for public figures to say I'm gonna be
an addiction treatment for sex addiction
and he always ends up doing the same
thing and even when his sentence is
served he will have to submit to
monitoring of his Internet activity
sounds like that could be awkward and he
will not be allowed to have contact with
the particular victim in this case he'll
also have to enroll in a sex offender
treatment program sexting just ruin this
guy's life yeah it started out as more
of a bizarre interesting kind of funny
story honestly yes Joe I mean obviously
was affecting his political career in
his marriage was never good but then he
went with this like third time of
sexting of a 15 year old girl and of
course he took a picture of himself with
his young child in the picture as wells
are you're gonna lose the public of that
ruined his career as a congressman in
2011 ruined his campaign for NYC mayor
in 2013 ruined his marriage to Hillary
Clinton advisor and confidant humi
Abbadon this even became an issue in the
2016 presidential election because
remember that the Comey Hillary
else thing kind of resurfaced because of
a bunch of emails related to Anthony
Weiner on he and humor Abaddon's home
computer which the FBI had to look into
whether or not involved any Hillary
Clinton stuff although of course James
Comey could have kept that private
opting not to but still connected to the
2016 election as well I do want to point
one thing out here when it comes to
Anthony Weiner I've heard nobody making
excuses for this guy you often hear from
the right oh the Democrats
and the left wingers they only care
about misdeeds from the right and they
ignore them when its misdeeds from the
left I've not seen a single person
defending Anthony Weiner I've been clear
that I thought that politically the guy
had a lot of potential he was very good
at debating he was very good at making
his points and getting his points across
politically on TV interviews and on
radio interviews so was Richard Nixon
right that doesn't mean I'm defending
the actions of Richard Nixon but I can
say Nixon was a very very smart guy I
think it's a very unfair criticism of
the left that they only care about
misdeeds when it's on the right because
can you think of anybody Pat who
defended Anthony Weiner I read I mean I
guess when after the first incident he's
making that comeback running for mayor
of New York yeah leading in some of the
polls he was and his wife I think was
alongside Frey then so you could say
well that's a de facto defense because
she's not leaving him at least after one
of these incidents but in the net this
is not a guy that Democrats are
defending in any way shape or form you
can make the case to forgive him at
first I guess because he was sexting
with a consenting adult Beyonc you move
on like I said to a fifteen-year-old
girl yeah publics not gonna be with you
anymore infidelity with adults is very
very different than starting to commit
crimes that relate to pseudo
pornographic material involving minors
that's when you're really gonna lose
gonna lose everybody and for me the most
classic moment not to make light of this
but the most classic moment of the
entire Anthony Weiner thing was when
Benjy Bronk of the Howard Stern Show
Fame got into one of the press
conferences I think it was the big press
conference where Anthony Weiner was
resigning as congressman and he started
yelling out just absolutely absurd but
comedic ly genius questions like will
you helped to support Arnold's love
child and were you fully erect in the
picture that you sent to that woman or
or were you capable of more if you've it
I don't know if you've seen that oh
that's like the lowest point in his
whole life and yes with the oa2 it's
probably just the timing of it could not
be worse but comedic Lee it was it was
absolutely an utterly brilliant the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad